the most compelling and controversial
political image of the week so far was
surely this
kiestama being mobbed by anti-vaccine
protesters some of whom repeated the
pm's controversial jimmy savile [ __ ] and
yet there was no mention of any of this
at today's pmqs first off boris johnson
announced all covered restrictions in
england could be scrapped within weeks
it is my expectation that we will be
able to end the last domestic
restrictions including the legal
requirement to self-isolate if you test
positive a full month early
then kia stammer focused on what his
team believe are big issues for people
across the uk the cost of living rising
energy bills and fraud was the business
secretary right to say that fraud is not
something that people experience in
their day-to-day lives the government is
insulting people's intelligence by
pretending it's giving them a discount
isn't it just forcing people to take out
a loan
now sky news analysis of zakir's
language today shows the words he used
most include billions pay pounds forcing
fraud government loan but also the word
chancellor now labour sources have told
me they have detected huge public
concern over the cost of living as well
as fraud and scams and they believe it's
the chancellor's biggest weakness so why
are they focusing on rishi sunak well
perhaps because they believe boris
johnson's reputation has already been
seriously damaged and now they're trying
to toxify one of those likely to succeed
him
on top of the tory tax rises on top of
the soaring prices the lone shark
chancellor and his unwitting sidekick
have now picked up a buy now pay later
scheme
well the prime minister's response to
the labour leader was to attack the
opposition's own approach to the crisis
over energy bills
what he would be doing mr speaker is
hitting the energy companies at
precisely the moment when we need to
encourage them to go for more gas mr
speaker because we need to transition
now to cleaner fuel
and sky news analysis boris johnson's
own language shows different words
appearing of course plan government
tackling country crime reason and
justice partygate was abating that very
row was reignited during pmqs when the
mirror newspaper published this photo
of the prime minister at a number 10
christmas quiz with what looks like on
the left a bottle of champagne mr
speaker in the last few minutes
a photo has emerged of the prime
minister in downing street on the 15th
of december 2020 surrounded by alcohol
food and people wearing tinsel it looks
a lot like one of the christmas parties
he told us never happened it's worth
noting from where i was sitting in the
press gallery fabian hamilton that mp's
question looked like it had been typed
out and therefore all of this may have
been a little less off the cuff and a
little more coordinated than it first
seemed but as soon as the new photo was
mentioned mps across the chamber started
looking at their phones and this was the
pm's response in what he has just said
i'm afraid he is completely in error
we know boris johnson has recently been
resetting refreshing and reshuffling his
team today we saw many of the appointees
in action including the new chief whip
chris heaton-harris taking a seat on the
government benches new number 10 chief
of staff steve barclay sitting next to
the pm and just behind not just mr
johnson's new policy chief andrew
griffith but his enlarged team of
parliamentary private secretaries four
mps armed with ring binders who passed
their boss briefing notes business
secretary quasi quarting was ticked off
by the speaker for heckling if you want
to carry on carry on outside i am not
having this perpetual noise coming from
the front bench secretary of state
should know better and i expect better
and right near the end in response to a
spiky question from senior tory mark
harper boris johnson made this
commitment on sue grey's inquiry as soon
as all the inquiries are concluded i
will immediately publish info whatever
sue grey gives me well the pm did
succeed in making it through today's
grilling without any scrapes and
parliament's half term recess starts
tomorrow so boris johnson now seems
pretty safe from a leadership challenge
until mps return here in 12 days time